هذه جبهة جديدة في الجدار الأوكراني لروسيا ،
يكافح عمال الطوارئ ألسنة اللهب الناجمة
عن الضربات الجوية على مدينة
دينيبرو بوسط أوكرانيا
ويقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون إن
مبنى سكني وروضة أطفال
ومصنع أحذية من طابقين قد تم استهدافهما وتدميرهما
مما تسبب في وقوع إصابات في الغرب في
أوكرانيا.  مدينة لوتسك على بعد 70 ميلاً فقط
من بولندا ، حليف الناتو ، تعرض
مطار استراتيجي أيضًا للهجوم مع
الغزو الآن في أسبوعه الثالث ،
ويبدو أن روسيا توسع
هجومها وهناك مخاوف من حدوث تصعيد ، كما أن
التلفزيون الرسمي الروسي
يبث هذه الصور للمقاتلين
من  قيل إن سوريا تتطوع
للانضمام إلى القتال من جانب روسيا ،
يدعم الكرملين نظام
بشار الأسد السوري وظهرت المشاهد
بعد وقت قصير من إبلاغ بوتين مجلس الأمن
بضرورة
دعوة المقاتلين الأجانب للانضمام
لذلك إذا رأيت أشخاصًا يريدون ذلك.
طواعية دون مقابل للحضور
ومساعدة الأشخاص الذين يعيشون في دونباس
جيدًا ، نحتاج إلى تلبية جهودهم و  د
ساعدهم على الوصول إلى منطقة القتال ،
هؤلاء بلطجية من سوريا ، قال
الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي من
البلاد التي دمرت بنفس الطريقة التي دمرنا
بها المحتلون كما قال
لاحقًا في اجتماع الكرملين مع
حليفه البيلاروسي الرئيس بوتين
لهجة مختلفة متفائلة قائلاً  تم
إبلاغه ببعض التحولات الإيجابية في
المفاوضات الأخيرة مع أوكرانيا
على الرغم من أنه لا يزال من غير الواضح ما
يمكن أن تكون عليه هذه التحولات الإيجابية ، لكن لا
يبدو أنها تحول روسيا عن
مسار الغزو ،
تشير صور الأقمار الصناعية الجديدة إلى وجود
عمود عسكري روسي ضخم شمال
تشتت العاصمة كييف الآن مع
إعادة تموضع بعض العناصر في الغابات
والريف حول
العاصمة وهذه هي أحدث الصور من
بلدة هشاكا الأوكرانية المحاصرة
في جنوب شرق البلاد تتحرك القوات الروسية
عبر الشوارع التي
يُقال الآن أنها تحت سيطرتها الكاملة
شيئًا فشيئًا أوكرانيا يبدو أنه يجري
تجاوز
فرصة ماثيو cnn kiev
الروسية  يقول المسؤولون إن
قواتهم الآن على بعد 15 ميلاً من الهدوء
من كييف تتحرك ببطء في الضواحي ،
ما رأيك في الوضع الأمني
ن في كييف ، هل تع
قد أنه يمكن تطويق القوات ال
وسية؟  m في kiev
في
centenki وأنت على حق ربما في 15 ميلاً
لدينا دبابات روسية لكنها لا
تتحرك لأن القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
أوقفتهم وخلال الأيام السبعة الماضية
لا يمكنهم التحرك مترًا واحدًا للأمام
ولكن لدينا أقل و  ذخيرة أقل
ولا نسمح بعدم الاستسلام ،
فنحن لا
نسامح أنهم وضعوا هذا النوع من
الأشياء وأنا واثق تمامًا من أننا
سنقاتل وكل منزل في
كل شارع وكل حي
في كييف في خاركيف في
كل المدن ستكون
جحيمًا للجنود الروس وستكون في
نهاية اليوم جحيم
بوتين ومع هذا الوضع فقط كلما
ساعدتنا في زيادة فعالية
المملكة المتحدة  القوات المسلحة الداخلية
سيتم وضع
الأضعف وهذا هو السبب في أن أمن
العالم كله لأمن الولايات المتحدة وأمن
الاتحاد الأوروبي وأمن الناتو سيكون أعلى من
فضلك ، نحن بحاجة إلى الاتحاد بنفس الطريقة التي
يرتكب بها بوتين الخطأ الثالث
الخطأ الأول
الذي
يبالغ في تقديره  يُظهر جيشه ونحن
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية ذلك وأنا
فخور بأنني كرئيس أنشأ هذا
الجيش في عام 2014.
النقطة الثانية أنه يقلل من أهمية
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
والنقطة الثالثة أنه
يقلل من وحدة الأوكرانيين التي
لا يستطيع تفجيرها.  أه كسر
وحدتنا وهو يستخف بوحدة
العالم كله
لأنه بعد 24 فبراير
الوحدة الأوروبية عبر الأطلسي الوحدة الأوروبية
للعالم كله تظاهر خلال
الجمعية العامة
للأمم المتحدة لكن خمس دول فقط
تدعم روسيا
وسوريا
إلى كوريا الشمالية وهذا  هو أساس
دعمهم ودعم 141
دولة لأوكرانيا في أوكرانيا
يوفر الآن بداية نهاية
الإمبراطورية الروسية